it's over it's over the
2024 presidential primary campaign has
not begun yet
but it's already over ron desantis go
home
ted cruz stay in texas nikki haley don't
even try
we know who the republican party nominee
is going to be
she's she's floating the idea of a
campaign it was so obvious
liz cheney is apparently entertaining
a 2024 republican bid
for president it really really is over
huh i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from donald trump j
on youtube who says impeach joe biden
save our nation oh my
sweet sweet child would that it were
so simple but it is not so simple
if you impeached joe biden do you know
what would change
absolutely nothing whatsoever because
joe biden is nobody joe biden
is a suit in human shape there's only
air blowing in between that suit
there is nothing that he wakes up in the
morning he puts his finger in the air he
feels the wind blowing he's
nothing but the avatar of the liberal
establishment which has power and which
exercises power and the
gop does not have any similar
institutional or cultural
sway which is why the gop today is like
herding a bunch of cats
it's so split it is so
absolutely out of its mind that liz
cheney is actually
considering running for president oh my
goodness do you remember the olden days
when the republicans used to be able to
exercise power gosh it was so far back
i can't remember them without the aid of
old slides old film reels old pictures
all of which can be digitally preserved
with legacy box
legacy box is a super simple mail-in
service to have all your video tapes
camcorder tapes film reels and pictures
digitally preserved on a thumb drive dvd
or
the cloud legacy box is a way for you to
easily and affordably preserve your past
this is something that i didn't know i
needed it until i needed it
until i lost every photo of a beloved
a relative of mine who had died
thankfully
i found the photos again they are now in
my possession first thing i'm going to
do send them off to legacy box they're
one wonderful way
to future proof your memories great for
mother's day too by the way for a
limited time legacy box is running a 50
off mother's day special order your
legacy box today to take advantage of
this incredible offer
one of the best discounts they've ever
offered it's perfect for you or someone
you love go to legacybox.comknowles
save 50 while supplies last that is
legacybox.com
knowlescannonwles liz cheney man
that lady is a representative
of the very desiccated
shallow ridiculous liberal wing of the
party that dominated for
i don't know the past 20 30 years or so
but has really fallen out of favor
especially
in beginning in 2016 and certainly
through 2020
liz cheney was one of the only people
on the republican side to vote to
impeach president trump even though
she's in
house republican leadership kevin
mccarthy
who is the republican leader in the
house has
finally come out and said you know this
liz cheney lady she's really making
things tough mccarthy made a good point
he said
there is a responsibility if you're
going to be in leadership
leaders eat last and when leaders try to
go out and not work as one team it
creates difficulties
when he says leaders eat last he's
referring to a buffet line
you go out there and you got to make
sure all your guys are fed first you got
to make sure you're taking care
of all the people in your team but liz
cheney doesn't do that
because liz cheney is not really a
republican
and what i mean by that i'm not just
saying she's a rhino you know this
this very often overused line what i'm
saying is
she doesn't care at all about the
republican party
obviously not she didn't vote for the
republican for president
i don't think she did in 2016 she
certainly didn't in 2020 then she voted
to impeach him
liz cheney represents her wing of the
democratic party call it the neocons
that's the term usually applied to it
meaning people who are very
very much supportive of adventurism
abroad
american empire abroad but don't
particularly care for conservative
priorities at home
that group of people made up one third
of the reagan coalition
you had the war hawk former democrat
types
in the reagan coalition then you had the
economic libertarians and then you had
the traditional conservatives
and the religious right in there as well
and
for the past 30 years or so after the
cold war when this coalition's been
trying to hobble along
the traditional conservatives they
always cave
the religious right always caves we go
along we get in line
we go along with say the libertarians
the libertarians sometimes cave
too particularly on foreign policy
but whatever we go along we get along we
vote we go with the nominee
and then that third group those warhawk
ex-liberal neocon whatever word you want
to use
they don't go along the minute they saw
a candidate that they don't like
namely donald trump they're out they
become never trump
they vote for some egg mcmuffin
candidate
they in 2020 vote for joe biden many of
them
well then you can't be part of the
coalition you can't
a political coalition doesn't work that
way if
two constituent parts of it always give
up everything for the team
and then the third part the minute they
don't get their way they don't go along
with it then you're just not on the team
and that's the issue with liz cheney
here
j i i suspect actually the reason
cheney's talking about running in 2024
is because she knows that her chances of
surviving a primary
are very very low for her congressional
race
so she's trying to pretend like she's
going to run for something else
no that isn't going to happen liz cheney
[Music]
who is the past of the gop raises this
question
if she's the past then what is the
future what is the future of the gop
and we have all everyone has different
sorts of answers i've got a very basic
answer
that i think is the bare minimum if the
gop is to have a future
if the gop is going to survive the gop
needs to be the party
of doing things doing things for a long
time
i know this sounds very basic but it's
something that the republican party i
think needs to hear
for a very long time the gop predicated
its entire identity on not doing things
they took up this sort of pseudo
quasi-libertarian language of
you know if the government that governs
best governs least
you know the government anytime the
government does anything it's
illegitimate taxation is theft whatever
all these kinds of slogans
the minute the government passes any
laws that's over regulation we got to
get rid of that we got to cut taxes we
got to do less and less and less
no never was particularly coherent
certainly isn't coherent right now going
up against a liberal establishment that
controls
everything the gop vision that will
have a future if it is to have a future
is a gop that does things give you an
example
the montana legislature yesterday
passed a bill prohibiting employers from
requiring their
employees to get the covid vaccine as a
condition of employment
this is a a regulation
that will be passed to create a new
requirement for
businesses to impede what businesses
want to do this is
big government if ever i saw it and i
love it
i'm really glad that the government is
going in
we the people or they the people of
montana
through their elected representatives
using the government to stop businesses
from doing what the businesses want to
do
to protect the rights and liberties
and traditional way of life of montanans
that's good that's i know some people
who are used to the libertarian language
they're going to say
i don't know regulation on business
that tells them they can't do what they
want to do that's a good thing
more regulation in this case means more
freedom
more regulation in this case means a
greater protection
of the american way of life when i think
of tradition
i want to go back to be
before all this crazy time when we have
everything as newfangled and highly
technical and all that
i want to go back to a simple time when
a man could grow out a beard
you know and a man could grow out a
beard and look like a caveman how
traditional is that well if you want you
can with beard supply
we all know that the absolute manliest
of men
are clean-shaven little swarthy have
hair slicked back
but there's another group that's just
below them that are very manly they grow
beards they grill meat they drink
handcrafted booze well thanks to the
manliest giveaway ever some lucky guy
will be doing those things for
free enter to win a stash of goods from
beard supply
meet church desert door haller brothers
and more
fabulous brands for the red-blooded
american male
one lucky bearded winner we'll get a
stash of beard oils and grooming
essentials from beard supply
tools for grilling leather care and a
200 shopping spree with the outdoor
menswear brand howler brothers
it's great you gotta up your game with a
stash of goods
to enter the beard supply spring
giveaway go to beardsupply.com
giveaway that is beardsupply.com
giveaway and good luck
winning the stash of goods
idaho just signed a great heartbeat bill
the idaho republican governor
brad little signed a bill on tuesday
that would ban
abortions after a fetal heartbeat can be
protected it's called the fetal
heartbeat
pre-born child protection act prohibits
medical providers from performing
abortion procedures
after a fetal heartbeat can be detected
which is around four to six weeks of
pregnancy
which would get rid of a whole lot of
abortions
a woman who receives an abortion would
be allowed to sue
the medical provider who provided it
really clever way to do this
because you the bat you're making the
abortionists the bad guys which is
important the way that
the pro-abortion people have been able
to advance their argument
it's not really an argument it's just an
emotional appeal is they say you want to
turn women who are desperate into
criminals no no we're just trying to
turn the abortionists into criminals
actually
and that seems fine by me and it
actually creates an incentive for the
women even the ones who've procured
abortions
to sue the people who provide the
abortions so it it
really puts a lot of pressure on the
abortionists love that fabulous
but this is big government this is a big
regulation
we can't come on we're the party of
personal choice there are many people
in the call it the liz cheney wing of
the party
the liberal wing of the republican party
that will vote for say pro-abortion
democrats
if the republicans nominate someone that
they don't like
there are a lot of them who will say no
we can't we can't do this when we have
big tent
right we need a big tent party for
pro-abortion people
we need a big tent party for people who
want to erase the fundamental
distinction in human nature
we need a big tent party for people who
want to go bomb the middle east but
we don't have a big tent party for
traditional conservatives we don't have
a big tent party
for old school so how big is the tent
really
the length this language of
personal choice is the be-all and
end-all of politics this was a trap
that was laid before us by
the liberal wing of the republican party
the adventurist overseas wing of the
republican party that would go bomb the
middle east as their
number one political priority it was a
trap
because politics cannot just be about
the formal question of personal choice
it has to be about what
choices we're making that's what we
decide in self-government
what about this issue of abortion in
idaho
you know that we have a devout catholic
president i don't know if you know that
the white house has really promoted this
idea a lot that the president he's a
devout catholic how dare you question
his catholicism
well he's really at odds with
the catholic church on a fundamental
question which is life
which as pope saint john paul ii pointed
out
is not just merely one issue among many
this issue of life
is a basic issue it's the basic right
from which all the other rights come so
a reporter asks
jensaki your devout catholic boss there
joe biden seems to be at
odds with the catholic bishops on this
issue of using
cells from aborted babies for scientific
research
you want to explain that for us jen saki
doesn't have much of an answer
as you well know the administration just
lifted the ban on researchers using
fetal tissue from elective abortions in
the u.s conference of catholic bishops
the leaders of the president's own faith
said in reaction
it is deeply offensive quote to millions
of americans for our tax dollars to be
used for research that collaborates with
an industry built
on the taking of innocent lives how does
the white house respond to that
criticism
look i think the white house specific or
respectfully disagrees
and we believe that it's important to
invest in science
and and look for opportunities to cure
diseases
and i think that's what this is hopeful
to do
yes the white house respectfully
disagrees with this with the bishops
you're not but you're not allowed to
respectfully disagree by the way
if you're a catholic on an issue such as
this there's no like well
you know you do you and i'll do me and
that's my personal choice and then we'll
all just go
sing the acoustic guitar songs at church
on sunday
no it doesn't work that way you've got
to make these choices and if you
if you diverge from the church from the
moral order on this issue
you are putting yourself in grave danger
you're making a decision
to not be a devout catholic
there this this idea of personal choice
doesn't take you very far
ultimately we will be judged on the
specific
choices so we need to start talking in
that kind of language because
with regard to joe biden and the
catholic church i'm speaking in a really
eternal sense here and in the long game
of judgment
but we will be judged as a political
party for the choices that we are making
here
this mealy-mouthed language of you do
you
ain't going to take us very far as a
party
either ben is going to be talking about
the all these crazy covet choices that
joe biden has made and how he's totally
blown it so make sure to check that out
also join us tonight for a special
episode of backstage
where we will finally be watching joe
biden's first congressional speech
live uh who knows if it's live i assume
it's pre-taped
for joe biden i just assume anytime joe
biden speaks it's pre-taped but he says
it's going to be live
we will certainly be live that's going
to be a lot of fun tonight 8 30 p.m
eastern 7 30 central on dailywire.com
and on our youtube channel over at daily
wire also we don't
have another great episode of candace
coming at you this friday
this week canvas is hosting dave rubin
they're gonna have a whole lot to
discuss
especially what's going on in california
my old failed state of uh
currently being run by new cellini with
the new potential opponent caitlyn
jenner yep
go check it out subscribe and stream
candace live on fridays at 9 pm eastern
8 pm central only at daily wire
25 off right now from a new membership
with code candace
at dailywire.com subscribe we will be
right back with a lot more
three cheers for big government once
again
in idaho idaho's passing a lot of great
bills right now
they passed that great heartbeat bill
and now they're passing a bill
to ban critical race theory in schools
this is hb 377 which will now be sent to
gop governor brad little
and i hope he signs it total
big government regulation here folks
limiting the choice and the specifically
the
academic freedom of teachers to teach
critical race theory oh it's so
backwards
so restrictive and oppressive and not
liberating and it's not for small
government and it's perfect it's
terrific i
love it i love it three positions on
critical race theory
there is the mandate critical race
theory that's the left wing position
there is the look if your school wants
to teach it that's fine but just don't
mandate it and just don't make me show
up to the mandatory training on
crt come on personal choice right that's
the kind of squishy
position on critical race theory then
there is the conservative position
which is that this is poison this is
this cuts at the heart not just of the
country
but of education itself and it needs to
be excised and banned
and cast into the outer darkness where
there is wailing and gnashing of teeth
that's the right view chesterton has a
great line
which is that there is a thought that
stops
thought and that is the only thought
that ought to be stopped
there is critical race theory is
among those thoughts that stop thought
critical race theory which is a
derivative of critical theory
which is a derivative of the western
marxist tradition that focuses much more
on culture
it is one of the key components of
political correctness
it's also one of the key aspects that i
discuss in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-order
you can you can even pre-order the
audiobook by the way because i've been
recording the audiobook for the past
couple days
it's been a lot of fun
one of the aspects of critical race
theory is not just that it castigates
america
as bigoted and racist and terrible and
it teaches children
who are educated in part to learn about
and love their country it teaches them
to do the opposite it teaches them to
hate their country so that alone would
suffice to get it banned
but critical race theory goes further
and it
it doubts the possibility of reason
itself
it undercuts the idea that we have
faculties of reason that we can know
things about the outside world the
objective reality
it it in many ways will
dismiss essential aspects of our
education
as mere excuses for white supremacy do
you remember a few years ago the
smithsonian
sent out a guide and it said that
language like
hard work and objective truth that's
those are just code words for white
supremacy so we got to get rid of hard
work and objective truth
that's the sort of gobbledygook and
nonsense that comes out of critical race
theory
so you see if you go into an educational
institution
and you teach people reason
and objective truth are false you have
not
expanded the curriculum you have not
opened students minds
you have undermined the entire education
you have limited education seems like
you're expanding it but you're actually
limiting it
so here in idaho they have a bill that
seems like it's a big government
intrusion on freedom
actually it is a it is a regulation
but it is expanding people's freedom it
is expanding people's education it is
making people more free
by imposing more limits on what these
lunatic teachers can do
that is fighting back by doing something
we need to fight back by do we're not
going to fight back by doing nothing
we're not going to fight back by using
the andrew breitbart doctrine as an
excuse to not actually
exercise political power breitbart said
politics is downstream of culture
fair enough like all slogans well
i'm sorry it is true some slogans are
not true at all
but like all slogans it is
not totally true yes culture influences
politics we need to make better
movies we need to take over cultural
institutions no doubt about that i'm 100
in agreement with that
but that is not an excuse for
politicians who we elect
to not do their jobs because politics
influences culture
too the example i keep going back to
is east germany east germany
is an atheist region
i think it's got a 10 rate of
religiosity
west germany greater than 50
self-identification
as religious what's the difference is it
just a is it a cultural difference in
the flavors of bratwurst in the two
areas no
it's a political difference because the
west was free
and east germany was dominated by an
officially communist
soviet regime for the cold war so the
berlin wall falls the soviet union falls
but the cultural effects of that
political regime
continue to dominate in east germany
so we need to be able to exercise that
too great way to do it
indiana governor eric holcomb just
signed a law last week
that will protect the state's churches
by designating them
as essential and forbidding state
authorities from treating them
differently than secular establishments
during public health emergencies you saw
this happen
i especially saw this happen firsthand
in california during
the height of last year's coronavirus
hysteria
churches were shut down you weren't
allowed to go inside churches you
were told then if you did go inside you
were not allowed to sing
you they really did persecute the
churches
but the marijuana dispensaries were
essential that had to stay open
that was an essential service you saw
this in other places where you know
churches were closed but casinos were
open let's say
that is not hypocrisy exactly it's a
hierarchy
certain things are more important to the
dominant liberal regime
than churches basically everything is
more important to the dominant liberal
regime
than churches that's just the
that's the state established church of
secular progressivism that we're living
under
so we need to fight back by passing a
big government regulation
that says that churches are essential
they're at least on par
with marijuana dispensaries and casinos
because
while politics is downstream of culture
there are some rivers in this world flow
in the other direction
and one might say with equal seriousness
that culture is downstream of politics
the left does not recognize the
religious character of its political
program
i think this is in part why
conservatives are so bad at
actually doing things in politics part
of it is because we've been tricked by
stupid cowardly language from the liz
cheney wing of the party for 20 years
but part of it is because we have
churches
part of it is because for the right
our policies are not everything you know
we do we have churches we have civic
associations we
have our families and the left has
less and less of that and they combine a
lot of these things
for the left their politics is
their religion i'm not the first guy to
say it
but more people are catching on to that
whereas the right is pretty clear yeah
here's my church
here's my religion here's my politics
here's how they interact is how they're
separate for the left they say we don't
have a religion
no we don't have a church we're
scientific
we just do what works you know whatever
our high priest dr fauci tells us to do
they don't understand they're not aware
of it but some people are waking up
like rose mcgowan who is this actress
she was very
central to the metoo movement rose went
on
fox news and came out and said that the
the democratic party is a replacement
church it's like a cult as some of you
know
some of you don't know if you've heard
my name or read anything on me in the
media
i grew up in a cult and it was a very
famous cult
called children of god and it gave me a
superpower
it gave me the ability to see the
control
and the propaganda machine especially in
the us
for what it is and how it harms people
and how the left can harm people just as
much
as the right if they go very very deep
into it
and ignore all other aspects of kind of
reality in a way
and and that you're serving a master
that might not be serving you and i
always say i come
in peace i am not here to make people
feel bad about their political choices
but i am here to say
that you might be in a cult too if you
don't know the signs and and i do
believe democrats most especially
are in a deep cult that they really
don't
and know about and aren't really aware
of and
i leave the republicans alone more
because i do
respect people more that are like this
is what we are
this is what we're about this is what
we're against
what she's saying here is not merely
that the democrats are a cult
i think that's true largely but that
sounds like a
relatively more shallow political hit
right that's just yeah you're in a cult
you're okay fine
but she's taking this further and making
a very insightful point here
she said at least for the republicans
who are in a cult
and you know culture and cult have a lot
to do with one another
people call all sorts of religions cult
but at least
for the republicans at least for the
people on the right they know that
they're in it
plenty of people call the catholic
church a cult i would call it the one
true church
i know that i'm in it i know i'm coming
i'm right out with you here i say i yes
i am in the catholic church which
believes certain things and doesn't
believe other things
maybe you're a methodist people call
that a cult well you're
very few people are methodists still
these days but let's say that you are
you know that you're in it you use that
term
people on the left don't know that
they're in it
they don't know that when they say that
a baby is not a baby
that a baby is a baby if the mother
wants the baby but a baby is not a baby
if the mother doesn't want a baby
that they are making a very
bizarre religious claim about personhood
and insolent and human dignity
they don't realize that when they say
that a man who believes that he is a
woman
is really a woman that they are making a
religious claim
called gnostic dualism in that
particular case
they don't they're not aware of that
they don't they don't possess the
language
to understand that they don't have the
sort of
philosophical or theological education
to make sense of that
and what rose mcgowan here is saying is
this is true even beyond these
most obviously philosophical and
theological questions this is true just
in the structure of the democratic party
people don't know that they're in the
cult you know one
two most famous things about cults what
are they
the two things you can always expect
from a cult
sex scandal financial scandal right this
is true of all human institutions
we were talking about the catholic
church before catholic church has faced
both of these sorts of things
sex scandal and financial scandal people
try to pretend that the catholic church
is the only group that's ever faced this
of course for those those who have
actually looked into the numbers
public school teachers are much more
likely to sexually abuse
children than members of the catholic
clergy
right the catholics in many ways were
singled out for this but this is true
throughout religious groups and it's
true certainly far more so in the
secular society
but financial scandals too there there
was that great documentary on the waco
siege
and this was it was a it was a docudrama
rather
and you know it's a kind of
fictionalized account of this
and there's a great line in it where the
fbi interrogator and
and uh negotiation guy is talking to the
people in the house and he said
hey you ever find it weird how all these
prophets of god always seem to
have sex with all the women yeah isn't
that kind of strange how they
god is always telling them to have sex
with all the women in that bizarre
so you see this especially in cults lots
of sex scandals but
more so even lots of financial scandals
we got that in blm blm
one of the most religious aspects
of the left establishment right now
right they provide
this idea that the pervasive sin that
has caused the fall of man is white
supremacy
and the only way that we can ever redeem
ourselves is by
chanting this this incantation black
lives matter black lives matter
performing these kind of rituals in the
streets this idea that
if you go out to i don't go to the
playground
during kovid you're killing everybody if
you go walk on the sidewalk you're going
to kill everybody with the virus but if
you show out by the thousands
and you loot and riot that that's
actually going to help solve the problem
of covid because it's going to solve
white supremacy public health officials
actually wrote that in a letter well
here comes the scandal
we know that blm now stands for by large
mansions
patrice culler is the co-founder of it's
been buying up lots of very swanky
property all around the place
she's denying any impropriety she says i
never took money from blm
not not in several years at least well
now we're finding out how she got the
money
according to campaign finance records an
la-based
jail reform group called reform la jails
founded and led by patrice cullers
made payments to multiple figures and
organizations
linked to colors herself including her
own consulting firm
as well as a luxury resort in malibu so
she was
she found an organization that is
affiliated with black lives matter
she then has the organization raise a
ton of money on the arguments presented
by black lives matter
then she pays her private company
through the organization
with the money raised because of the
arguments made by black lives matter
so she paid herself just through that
one organization and that one place to
that one company
60 grand she paid another 44 grand to
bowers consulting firm whose founder and
president
shalamiya bowers appears to be a board
member on another non-profit founded by
colors dignity and power
now it is my friends
a racket but this is how political
organization that is effective is really
done
people amass positions of influence
within the culture and they raise big
money
and they wield that big money for big
political influence and there's no
doesn't matter how much we investigate
this woman
there's very little that we can do about
it because she's got the power
because the liberal establishment more
broadly has the power
we can point it out but if we're not
willing to wield power it's not
not going to matter very much that and a
buck 50 will get us
a cup of coffee
blm is not the only left-wing
organization that's got a financial
scandal right now
a former obama white house advisor has
been caught stealing money
reportedly from a charter school network
that he founded
very similar scandal to the scandal that
we're seeing from
patrice cullers at blm except that she
was apparently a little
more clever about it federal authorities
arrested the former obama white house
adviser seth andrew
for allegedly stealing hundreds of
thousands of dollars from a charter
school network that he founded
doj announced this in a press release
he's facing charges of
wire fraud money laundering and making
false statements to a financial
institution
related to a scheme stealing a couple
hundred grand
it's amazing that these people would
destroy their lives
for 200 grand but he got caught that's
the problem
blm appears to be doing all the same
sort of stuff they found
these non-profits for for the prisoners
for the people for the oppressed and
then they use that to send money to
their own
private companies which are going to
send money back to these people
which are going to pay off political
favors to other people on the boards of
other organizations that are going to
raise more money
they're just better at it it's the same
sort of thing
so what i am suggesting i know this is
radical is
what if we build up political
organizations that are just as effective
i don't want them to be dishonest i
don't want them to be immoral
i don't want them to be unjust i don't
think we have to but i think we can
build up
political organizations that can
influence
private companies and influence the
government just like blm has
that do have lots of money how much
money to blm raises something like 90
million dollars
so much money that you had the blm act
activists activists
in ferguson demanding a cut they say
give us a little taste
how come you guys are making all that
money blm new york is now looking at
patrice colors and saying hey how come
you're getting all that money give us
some of that money
a lot of money in these organizations
what if we did it the right way in the
moral way but we
did it nonetheless so that we could
wield real political power
right now john kerry is being accused of
some serious impropriety john kerry is
the climate czar in the biden
administration
he is being accused of
leaking information to the iranian
foreign minister who's his very good
friend
javad zarif we used to we used to make
fun of this when
john kerry was the secretary of state
we'd say he'd spend his days
javad hello javi javi baby i'm sorry
what they're doing to you honey
but we're don't worry i mean he would
actually he was caught
back channeling to javad zarif during
the trump administration and saying hey
don't pay attention to this guy we'll
switch things don't come on don't rip up
the iran deal come on baby please
so the iranian foreign minister javad
has revealed in a leaked phone call that
kerry told iran
that israel was behind hundreds of
attacks on iranian assets in syria
hey jensaki do you have an answer about
this come on what's the answer here
in tapes obtained by the new york times
iran's foreign minister says that former
secretary
of state john kerry informed him that
israel attacked iranian interests at
least
200 times um you know as the secretary
has shifted roles
uh he still continues to represent the
united states on a world stage
does the president have any comment or
reaction to carrie telling the iranians
about covert military action on the part
of israel
we're not going to comment on leaked
tapes we're not going to comment
on that because it's obviously true so
we're
we're just not going to comment on that
and she doesn't have to comment she'll
get one question maybe from a reporter
in the room
very few people are going to cover this
this is probably one of the few shows
that's going to cover this
she doesn't need to give an answer
because she is an avatar of the left
which has
institutional power and so they just
don't need to worry about this sort of
thing
and if the right wants to to affect
anything
if the right wants to advance its agenda
it's not enough to have the best
arguments
it's not enough even to have the best
candidates we need to amass
institutional power
and then we need to know how to use it
i'm michael knowles this michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 our lords and
masters and the cdc in the white house
have blessed us with new covid
guidelines
justin bieber is accused of cultural
appropriation for wearing dreadlocks
and we'll deal with the claim that there
is systemic racism against black nfl
players somehow
all of that and more today on the matt
walsh show